die letzte folge dieser serie ist
fucking ewig her ich glaube das letzte
mal habe ich vor zwei monaten essen
getestet das andere youtuber hast das
war genauso wie menschliche heute meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren er kennt
ihr vielleicht schlafmittel und wenn ihr
trolle zuschauer von sony seien
ich habe gehört wie man heute zusammen
einkaufen da fragte was habe ich mit
jemand anderem ist vormittag hineingeht
wieder während diverse wunderbare
köstlichkeiten eingekauft gegessen
werden
und da habe ich gehört habe schon mal
einmal raus geholt
ich dachte ich biete das recht von
anfang okay da würd ich sagen fangen wir
an mit einer wunderbaren kleinigkeit die
wir soeben aus dem regal gegriffen haben
ganz ehrlich der großteil der sachen ist
schon abartig ich will sagen wir haben
uns einfach mal auf ganz entspannt
da wird man richtig war mit einfach
einem blauschimmelkäse ich denke dann
einfach mal so dass du einfach so rein
hallo diese hektische zeit leisten ein
körbchen ist es so ein geräusch käse
macht defour ist einfach
blauschimmelkäse ist schimmel drauf
wer ist denn in seiner freizeit du bist
okay machen wir mal kurz zu 1 schoss als
blauschimmelkäse modeljob ist laut
schmid noch mal so ein schrott alter ok
direkt kauft mir wohl punkt auf der fall
sony ab 100000 euro pro pos zu haben
okay dann erst jetzt gehören dir doch
mal also waren wir nicht so oft schießen
sie machen wir nicht so auf schlecht
diese und also eine kleine ecke kann
immer etwas hunger und der geschmack
scheint nicht so schlimm zu sein ist
noch alles spart mal ganz kurze frage so
ganz kurze verschwörungstheorie stell
dir mal vor blauschimmelkäse würde
verschimmeln würdest das merken
schon mysteriöse jasid sei material
stimmt aber nicht so wie man es erwartet
habe ja aber er schmeckt wie käse mal
hat moore wurde versteht aber anders
würde ich mich gut was widerrief das
wieder nicht einfach aus man etwas eben
sagen wollte mein gesagt ja also diesen
kiel zuerst unglückliche der hand hatte
war welche so nicht
also wenn ihr schon käse milch oder
eltern verwandte freunde
es war für die konsistenz schon mal
wieso kommen wir einfach ja genau man
ist einfach fast hört man stings stimme
vor damit oder beträgt ich mein wissen
und so sein wissen ja okay du hast
gerade schon das bedürfnis gehabt mit
der orange monate etwas runter zu
spielen
wie wärs wenn du mit dem neuesten
trailer okay ganz kurz dazu warum ist
wie ein leckerer erdbeer drink in deiner
liste von gästen lebensmitteln ganz kurz
wie war das für dich herauszufinden dass
milch mit geschmack existiert der
verpackung unter wieder einfriert man
hat schon aufgegessen
ich weiß was du meinst ja wenn es ein
bisschen wärmer wird beim trinken aber
kommt es richtig geil oder sich so schön
projekt richtig traurig so ganz kurz
noch der drinks night passend zu den
fingernägeln hast du die passend zum
ertönen heute ausgewählt okay dann muss
man halt deine gerade auf 150000
gestiegen aber die massenmedien nicht
mit bodo h
in meinem mund ist jetzt nicht schlimm
finde du musst jetzt zweiter trinken
ok hast du gesagt ich verstehe natürlich
geil heimische milch mit seiner apple
müht man sich gerne und ich hab immer so
kälte das leute dieses paar ströme nur
mit seinem geschmack story war das neue
cool drauf aber weil das macht keinen
spaß zu trinken dass er ist es eben war
das für mich einfach ein fucking geile
herz für seine ehre möchte
die kurzen pausen im leben genießen
möchte und dann kommst du und erzählte
was von speicher schmeckt genauso sagt
aus kuba sollten also spucken
ok mache weiter jetzt mit einer sache
die ich noch nie gegessen habe und ich
weiß auch nicht wie man die ist aber die
nächste sache ist das was ist das
problem damit und ich war mir selbst zu
sagen okay und herzlich geliebt und dann
wollte ich von ihnen tun als nicht
auffällig
geschmiert und schädlich weil man sich
getroffen und nicht zu eröffnen dann
muss ich kosten
bis direkt auslöffeln
wie sieht es aus ist einfach ist einfach
so cremige nutella oder von dem so ein
sympathischer mal denke das ganze
irgendwie und comedy konzepts ist die
ist sowieso ein pudding den man so auf
streicht war das ist schon echt ihrem
los ist so käser nutella oder ich denke
das ist schon gespannt wie du hast du
vielleicht kann auch leute die das leben
okay dann haben wir hier die trauben
scheibe toast der toast muss ich sagen
hat den geschmack bisschen verdächtiger
inspur einmal nacht
doch da hat das kommt von jemandem der
früher warm trocken und heller gelöffelt
hat okay nicht so gezeugten doch so
machte ich habe nur etwas bewirken
wenn man nicht durch die nase
mit großem hallo das ist keine mutter
war mcclaren
ich schätze es jetzt erst ich dachte die
ganze täler philadelphia
nein das ist mir zu tun ein denkmal
einmal jetzt nur daran wie siehst du das
lag aber mein gott ich weiß ich kann das
nicht kann mir das nicht vorstellen ich
ganz ehrlich wir achten auf eine
ausgewogene ernährung oder ist ein
klarer fall für mich deswegen heißt es
dass nach und süß herzhaft kommt wir
haben einen polster salat also ein
krautsalat mit einer ganz abartigen soße
außen rum und wir haben wieder wird die
zauberhafte produkt testerin sony am
heutigen tage in unserem studio
ich führe das diesen krautsalat sich
einfach mal aggressiv fahren würde
[Musik]
wieso zurückgezogen
ich finde wie berichtet die konsistent
ist auch wieder so speicher kann es denn
du hast heute somit speicher konsistenz
her okay weißt du was das ist ein spaß
ist leider richtig mit der ich glaube
das geht gar nicht
ich hatte so krauth an die liebste da
sind
es ist ein lifestyle produkt was du auf
jeden fall regelmäßig konsumieren
würdest würdest du ein leichter
beschreiben müssen mystery muss kurz den
gästen gefällt ich weiß nicht also du
wirst danach nach diesen salat schmecken
die ganze zeit sagt also munter
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
konsistenz vielleicht wirklich aber
generell betrifft gemacht werden
marcel bock auf dem einfach entspannt
krautsalat für dich geholt das willst du
so etwas hat unsere gewichtung definitiv
nein das was von diesem video das nicht
auch eine beschreibung von links auf
jeden fall ab und jacky über sondern ist
kommt noch einfacher